Ford Motor Company announced that they were
going to be laying off thousands of workers,
7,000 to be exact, 7,000 Ford employees, salaried
white collar, Ford employees, people making
good wages with good benefits, had good jobs.
7,000 are being laid off.
900 alone just this week, 500 of those here
in the United States, the remainder working
for Ford overseas.
So not all 7,000 I guess are coming from the
United States.
So I, I guess that's a plus, right?
But I think Bernie Sanders actually did the
best job of summing up why this is such a
disgusting story.
This is what Bernie tweeted on Monday after
Ford made this announcement.
He said, Ford Gut nearly 750 million in tax
breaks from the Trump tax scam and paid at
CEO 18 million last year.
Now Ford is laying off thousands of workers.
The bottom line Republican sold the tax scam
as a way to create jobs and help workers.
They lied.
And that's 100% correct because Ford is estimated
that this is going to save them 600 million
ish a year, maybe 650 million a year.
Yeah, but you already got 750 million in tax
breaks from the Republican Party.
So even pocketing an extra $750 million a
year wasn't good enough for you.
You want to save an extra 650 million a year
so that you can bring your total savings to
one point $4 billion a year by laying off
people, by destroying American jobs, by ruining
households, by kicking their top earner out
into the street.
That's what's happening to the men and women
at Ford and it's happening to 500 of them
by Friday of this week and Bernie's also right
in the fact that Republicans promised us corporations,
we're going to save money, but that money
was going to go back and it was going to create
jobs.
They were going to invest in their own companies.
They were going to expand that.
We're going to give you better benefits.
They were going to give you bonuses.
Remember that all the hype around the few
companies that gave a handful of their employees
$1,000 at the end of that year right after
the tax scam past those bonuses didn't come
back.
This past year incorporations corporations
admitted that they weren't going to come back
ever.
Those were one time.
It was basically a publicity stunt and it
worked.
Oh, and also fewer than 13% of the companies
who got the Donald Trump Republican tax scam
cut.
Only 13% actually spend it on their businesses.
The rest of the money went to shareholder
dividends and buying back their own stock
with stock buybacks are also at an all time
high and that's because of the Republican
tax scam.
They don't care about expanding their businesses.
They are already, most of them the size that
they want to be.
What they care about if they're going to invest
in their own company is automation.
How do we get rid of the human beings and
replaced them with a machine that is happening
here, happens with automotive companies like
Ford especially.
But the bottom line is that we were lied to.
A majority of people in this country do understand
that there's very few people out there today
in the, uh, you know, middle class or the
working class or the, the underclass who say
that no, this tax scam was a good idea.
Even Republicans who are in those demographics
say that no, it was a lie.
We're not gonna get anything.
Nobody buys trickled down anymore.
Except of course for the top 1% and corporations
because they're the only ones who benefit
from it.
Unfortunately, a lot of members of Congress
happened to be in the top 1%.
So they all benefited from their own tax cut
package.
In fact, one of them, the congressman from
Florida, who's name escapes me at the moment,
uh, the day after the day, excuse me, that
he voted for the tax cut package.
After he cast his vote, he then left Congress
and went and closed on a new yacht and the
yacht happened to be in the same value that
he was expected to save onto the new tax bill.
That's what this was about.
Putting more money in the pockets of rich
people putting more money into the bank accounts
are Ford not caring one bit whether or not
they actually spent that money on their employees
or if they kept the jobs that they already
had or if they even shipped them overseas,
they didn't care.
And that's another thing is that Trump promised
us multiple times throughout his presidency
that he was going to make Ford keep their
jobs here in the United States.
I remember he said it was gonna happen with
forward, who's going to happen with carrier?
Pretty much it was going to happen with Foxconn
and Wisconsin.
Bringing all these new jobs in.
Everything Donald Trump has touted of creating
jobs or keeping jobs here in the United States
has been an absolute lie.
But instead of saying, Oh crud, I'm really
horrible at negotiating with these countries,
uh, companies.
What did he do yesterday after Ford made this
announcement, he headed the Pennsylvania to
give another one of his hate filled rallies
where at some point they were once again chanting,
lock her up.
Can you imagine, can you imagine being obsessed
with Hillary Clinton that much here in 2019
in May of 2019 still being obsessed with Hillary
Clinton.
I didn't even care which side of the aisle
you're on.
Obsessor with Hillary Clinton needs to go
away now.
But nonetheless, he wasn't out there saying
that, oh, we do have a problem.
Companies are cutting jobs and I'm going to
have to get tough with them.
No, he went into his usual talking points
about how great everything is, how much he's
kicking.
Sean has bought in the trade war.
You know how stupid the Democrats are, how
fake the news is.
He didn't talk about the fact that everything
is a lie.
The economy is not doing great.
It looks great on paper, but when you actually
go out there and you start to look at it,
when you read the Labor reports, which I hate
to admit that I actually have done, it's boring.
It's tedious, but they do not paint a picture
of a rosy economy.
We're not adding jobs that actually matter.
In fact, as Ford pointed out this week, we're
losing those good jobs and replacing them
with minimum wage, seasonal or temporary workers.
The economy is not doing great, but Donald
Trump would rather continue whistling past
the graveyard, pretending that he is the great
economic savior of the United States, and
unfortunately too many people who show up
to those mag rallies actually believe that.